but tell me about your company italic
and how did you come up with the idea
and how's it going so far
yeah sure so uh italic is what i like to
say is it's a marketplace that connects
high-end manufacturers behind some of
the world's top brands
directly to end consumers who can
purchase those same quality products uh
for anywhere from let's say 50 to 80
lower than let's say if they bought that
from a brand or retailer
we've been around for about three years
it's been pretty good i think we've
stayed under the radar for a while um we
now have about
70 or so manufacturers a couple hundred
products ranging from cookware from the
same factories as all clad um and
stout to
let's say sweaters from the same
manufacturers as you know
sandro and and uh and betting from the
same factories it's like four seasons um
say if you're just you know so on and so
forth and
we've been able to i think a massive
pretty
loyal customer base um and uh and in
terms of the idea that the short of it
is i i um
my family's been in manufacturing for 40
50 years it's uh
in china
yeah and yeah mostly china but we've had
some stuff in europe and in south
america and um and the way i like to say
it is if you if you know anything about
manufacturing it's literally the worst
business in the world
um it is super low margin super
competitive you're selling what is
essentially a commoditized service for
the lowest possible cost and
um and your clients you know are really
the ones who make the most uh
in terms of the margin
you simply provide a value added service
you take your margin and then you kind
of give it to someone else who takes the
inventory risk and sells it five ten
times what they paid you know you for so
i think in in
the past couple years before italic i
started kind of thinking about hey what
can we do for
um the manufacturing side and the supply
side of the world especially in the
whole like heyday of you know a lot of
these direct consumer customer um uh
consumer brands that had popped up over
the past decade and um and i think
that's actually kind of a misnomer
because uh originally they did cut out
the retailer so
they were able to kind of pass on some
of the savings to the brand
but now that earth to the consumer but
now that facebook and google are so
competitive and so expensive
you know um it's effectively the same
product uh as let's say a legacy brand
um in the same cost structure you're
saying so you know somebody who is
selling you know a sunglass hut he has
to do a retail store but then
you know um warby parker has to have you
know an online presence and they have to
pay for traffic so one's paying for it
and giving the money to facebook for
google for customers the other one is
giving the money to
um a landlord for traffic exactly so
when i look at the site and i see
sunglasses and i say oh wow these
sunglasses these hancock round acetate
sunglasses they look great by the way
i've always wanted to own a pair of
these but they're really expensive so i
don't like to buy expensive sunglasses
and these are only 30 bucks and it told
me hey these are like lacoste am i
practicing lacoste correctly
and then super drying chanel uh channel
i don't know what this channel is no
chanel so what they're saying is the
past clients of the people who made
these glasses
that factory has you're not saying these
are the same glasses as chanel or super
dry to be clear you're saying that
factory previously had customers
including chanel and super dry correct
exactly yep that's right um and the
whole value prop is uh that's kind of
how we build the the quality association
is like hey this is a legit product
that's not just like your average kind
of correct consumer brand that buys low
cells high um but uh this manufacturer
who used to produce for these kind of
clients you should expect a high quality
assume um similar to those brands
and it says here that they're zeiss
lenses i'm assuming carl zeiss lenses
which are very high-end i think german
lenses
i'm not sure if they're actually made
there or not
so
let me just be frank here in another
world
before you existed sometimes these
factories i'm not saying the ones you
work with might run off an extra
thousand pair of chanel glasses and they
might sell them on a marketplace like
ebay or alibaba as knockoffs uh or on
canal street in new york and there were
counterfeits in a way is what you've
done said to those same factories listen
you don't need to counterfeit that's
wrong that's illegal you're infringing
on people's ip
but you are
a sunglass manufacturer and you have
this factory you're entitled to make
your own brand we will enable you to
sell directly to the same comp customers
all you need to do is make a great
product that we approve of is am i
correct that that that's what's
happening here ecosystem-wise
yeah i think that's kind of the a good
gist of it and really the
incentive here for the manufacturer if
you think about it is like why are they
doing that in the first place um really
it's the only channel you know
that a manufacturer has to
generate revenue is to go get another
client um who it's the same model as
always like uh you start with a model uh
you start with an order um the
manufacturer maybe makes 20 25 on top of
cost of goods um so if it's like a ten
dollar you know product they're making
two to they're gonna have two to uh 250
on top of that ten dollar
cost per unit um and then they'll
they'll sell it to a brand who's
ultimately going to sell that for let's
say 60 70 80 sometimes like 100 bucks um
uh uh and the brand actually keeps the
majority of the margin and whether they
sell to the retailer or to
you know directly to a consumer it's
still the same kind of playbook there um
so as a manufacturer like the only way
you can grow your business is by adding
more and more clients or by increasing
the volume of production that these guys
are running and they're in a trap it's a
race to the bottom there's no way for
them ever to make margin so what you've
done is said hey listen
make a high quality product you don't
have to worry about doing the ad
campaign of chanel you don't have to
worry about building a presence in the
united states will be that presence for
you and you've essentially created a
house brand like amazon or whole foods
365 or amazon basics but these are
anything but basics i'm looking at like
the suede jackets and the hoodies
um they're not cheap they are they do
seem to fit into what i would call value
am i correct and how you're positioning
this like
there it's value so you save 50 but it's
not like buying whatever that like 10
amazon really junky thing that falls
apart
yeah we want to provide uh essentially
the highest quality product possible for
the lowest possible price point and that
doesn't necessarily mean it's going to
be the cheapest it also doesn't mean
it's going to be like the most luxe kind
of artisan made product but at the same
time i think for the majority of the
people
who are shopping online like that's
actually a value proposition that people
can get behind um
i think really it speaks to the
alignment of incentives
our customers uh historically they're
always told like hey to buy something
nice you have to pay a lot of money for
it or if you want something cheap it's
gonna break after you know two to three
wears if it's apparel um and uh and i
think that the notion with italic is
like actually if you remove the biggest
middle of menovault which is the brand
um you're actually able to deliver that
high quality product but for a mass
market price point
which reminds me of uniqlo that seems to
be the closest to what you're doing
okay everybody let's take a moment to
talk about growth marketing and all the
tactics and hacks that are out there
with me today jake badgard he is the ceo
and founder of disruptive advertising
which you can visit at
disruptiveadvertising.com
twist
so some questions for you jake what are
some of the tips you have for marketers
who are planning to take advantage of
black friday and cyber monday this year
yeah jason 2020 was a phenomenal year
for black friday and cyber monday and
2021 is shaping up to be as good if not
better we actually have a benchmark
report where we're
monitoring 250 million dollars in media
budgets and we're seeing that cpms are
starting to rise in the 20 to 40 percent
range in a lot of industries
and so i i'm just worried that a lot of
companies are going to get surprised
that there's a lot of demand but the
competition is up as well
and if they don't have a good strategy
for that they're going to spend the same
amount and get less performance or
they're going to have to spend a lot
more to get the same performance and so
they've got to get on top of that so if
you want to sign up for a free digital
marketing audit with jake and his
company disruptive advertising just
visit disruptive
disruptiveadvertising.com twist and if
you go into business with disruptive you
will receive a 250 gift card and a free
friday to sunday ski trip in utah uh
we'll see you on the slopes gonna be a
great season